hi everyone
welcome uh i'm delighted to
um invite you all today to uh the post
talk discussion
from our monthly uh colloquium on the
inference series
so as you all know as part of this
cross-disciplinary
project under trying to understand the
nature of
inference looking at correlation and
cause it causation
we have a series and we have
distinguished speakers
who give a lecture and in the following
the following day we have a post-doc
talk conversation uh with another
distinguished scholar who represents a
slightly different point of view
who will uh speak to the um
the lecturer and answer lots of
questions that uh
we might have and also bring in some
additional perspective
to uh the the uh topic of discussion
so um before uh we
delve into the discussion i would like
to thank
our benefactors mr and mrs richard and
barbara frankie
whose support of this program and many
other
activities at gra at yale is gratefully
acknowledged
and i also want to remind you once again
that uh you know we are recording this
event
and the recording will be available on
our website and as a result all
participants must mute their videos and
of course as always if you wish
uh please go ahead and start submitting
your questions
through the chat and dr kemp and i will
at the end of the conversation uh pass
on your questions
to both our conversants today so just a
quick
um a reminder that our speaker yesterday
was the distinguished philosopher
of science lorenzo magnani
professor manyani is on the faculty in
the department of humanities in the
philosophy section
and he's also the director of the
computational philosophy laboratory at
the university of pavia
um in italy he is
truly interdisciplinary in his
intellectual interests he's a
philosopher
epistemologist and cognitive scientist
and he spoke to us yesterday about the
power
and the limits of scientific models
so we are really fortunate to have as
the conversant for
our post-doc conversation today uh
professor james wetherall
who is the professor of a professor of
logic and philosophy of science at the
university of california
at irvine and i'm also delighted
uh to let you know that jim is one of
the core members of our team
uh on this project trying to understand
the nature of inference
so um professor witherall
has been at uc irvine where he's also a
member
of the institute for mathematical
behavioral sciences and the center for
cosmology
also another exemplar of true
cross-disciplinary scholarship
his most recent book which is absolutely
fabulous
is the misinformation age how false
beliefs spread
which is co-authored with kailyn
o'connor and it
explores the social dynamics of belief
in evidence-rich environments
and he has another fabulous previous
book called
void that was also published both these
books are published by yale university
press
and he had an intriguingly titled book
which i have not read
is called the physics of wall street
which was published as a trade book
so his research interest concerns sort
of a variety of intellectual issues
in the mathematical and conceptual
foundations of physics
philosophy of cosmology and social
epistemology
and before we um before i invite them
to start conversing i just wanted to
remind you to
take a look at our webpage for the
learning by doing project
and the fact remind you that we have
this monthly colloquium series which
will continue through the summer
and our final frankie program event book
talk
for uh the semester is linda lynn hopps
who is the author of mozart starling and
that's on april 27th
at 4 p.m okay without further ado i
would like to invite
lorenzo and jim to um
have this conversation that we are
waiting to hear
um and learn from thank you so much
for coming thank you thank you thank you
uh so i i actually uh if you don't mind
i prepared some
some slides following the model of uh
some of our uh
previous uh events here just just a few
of them
um so i'm gonna go ahead and
share this
screen here
um okay can everyone see the uh
yep great
okay great um so uh
i just wanted to you know begin by um uh
by
uh thanking uh professor magnani for his
uh talk yesterday it was it was very
stimulating
um and uh um
i'm going to uh try to
um highlight a few features of the talk
i have two sort of
big questions that will will come up uh
along the way
um and uh which i'll sort of return to
at the
uh the very end here um
partly this is a reflection of having
been inspired by some of the ideas
that uh professor magnani presented
yesterday
um but partly i'd also like to to um
get into a little bit more about just
what's at stake
in um some of the the uh
issues that were raised yesterday um
just to begin though
you know i appreciate that this is an
interdisciplinary
audience and so i thought it might be
helpful to give a little bit of
of context for uh some of the
um the the debates that we saw um
reflected in the talk yesterday and so
um to begin here uh
we're working within a certain
historical context in
philosophy of science so philosophy of
science
as a sort of stand-alone discipline
emerged in the beginning of the 20th
century
following work in mathematics and in
physics
in the late 19th century and early 20th
century
um much of the early 20th century work
in philosophy of science
emphasize the role of theories
in science there are lots of reasons for
this i don't need to get into
but the basic picture was one where
theories could be thought of as sets of
sentences they were assertions about the
world
um they did various sorts of things that
they were understood to make predictions
um they were understood to be the sorts
of things that could be confirmed or
falsified um uh
eventually philosophers came around to
recognizing that theories could play a
role in explanations
um the way that they would do this would
be by warranting particular inferences
and so explanation and prediction were
quite closely connected to one another
um and within that context you had
you know views about what science
did like what what's what it meant for a
successful scientific theory to
to be successful and so one attitude
that people had was
you know a realist attitude we would say
that a successful scientific theory
was one that was true it it makes
assertions about the world
and those those assertions are true or
approximately true
um anti-realist meanwhile would say that
no what theories did
was they somehow organized relations
between possible observations the
theories themselves
didn't make true assertions um they
were merely perhaps empirically adequate
or
um uh led to successful predictions
without doing more
okay but so that's only part of what
science is
maybe according to some people anyway a
small part of what science is
and during the final third of the 20th
century you began seeing within
philosophy of science
um increasing emphasis on other aspects
of scientific practice
and in particular philosophers began to
highlight the fact that
um formulating testing and extracting
explanations from theory
isn't the whole story much of science
consists
of model based reasoning and so
to really understand science one must
study not just theories but also
uh or even instead models
but now within a context where much of
the work that have been done so far
in philosophy of science had focused on
these sort of big questions
concerning theories like um what does it
mean to confirm a theory
how do theories explain and uh
you know are our theories true or
approximately true
um the the huge diversity of things that
we saw
when we started looking into model based
reasoning and science
looked odd it wasn't clear what it would
mean for instance
to say that a model was true or false or
to confirm a model
the kinds of explanations that models
seem to enter into
didn't fit into the kind of framework
that uh
um uh was it you know people had built
for for thinking about
theoretical explanations previously and
perhaps most importantly or most
puzzlingly
models seem to stand in a very different
kind of representational relation
to the world then people understood
theories too
right theories were sentences that
asserted things about the world
models um seemed to have a more semantic
character they looked like they were
structures of some sort
that had some other kind of relationship
and so people began trying to develop
ideas about that
right so what how should we think about
models and what does it mean
for models to succeed so
you started seeing proposals like models
are structures perhaps abstract
structures mathematical structures
maybe real physical structures that are
in some way isomorphic to or partially
isomorphic to
some part of the world or perhaps
they're just similar to the world in a
way that's um
not quite as rigid as isomorphism
although also a bit more difficult to
try to make precise
it's in that context that people began
proposing ideas
of a sort that we saw discussed
yesterday like perhaps it's possible
that models are representations of
imaginary systems
that are in some ways analogous to the
kinds of
imagination that happens in the context
of
fiction um we also see
discussions and this is not supposed to
be a an exhaustive list
but the idea that maybe actually models
are more like art
than like fiction right and so boss von
frosten has defended this idea
that we should think of models as
representations
as we depict the world as having
certain kinds of of key properties that
are
are captured by the model and what we
see here
in these different options is a
characteristic
philosophical response to
a you know looking at a new kind of of
um
scientific practice which is that we
need an account
now this is the sort of thing that we
saw with explanation earlier in the 20th
century
we want to say that an explanation is
part of science what we need to do is
come up with an account of what
makes an explanation an adequately
scientific one
the idea is to give necessary and
sufficient conditions
for being an explanation and then to try
to
uh show that all explanations within
science have this character
um something similar happened with
modeling the scientific modeling this
sort of in the 1980s 1990s even into the
2000s you started seeing
these accounts
of modeling of scientific models that
were presented as
attempts to
somehow say once and for all what all
models were like
and how they worked in the background
there were sort of
two big questions you can roughly think
of as a metaphysical question an
epistemological question
so one question is what are scientific
models are they are they structured are
they abstract are they concrete are they
fictions are they something else
the sorts of things that i think we saw
discussed yesterday and then something
else we saw discussed yesterday
how do scientific models
produce knowledge as the epistemological
question
okay so that's the context here now
i want to um highlight something that
uh um i think appeared in professor
manyani's talk yesterday
that seems to me to be right on the
money um
something that uh seems to to not be as
widely
uh um recognized within the philosophy
of modeling
uh community as um
i would like to see but you know which i
i think was was on display
very nicely yesterday which is that
scientific models are heterogeneous
they're extremely heterogeneous
they um seem to enter into lots of
different kinds of arguments they're
used for many different sorts of
purposes
um professor magnani pointed to this
book that he had co-edited
um that it was over a thousand pages
of you know descriptions of different
kinds of models
and the role that they play in uh
different areas of science
that i think just you know um
you know provides a bestiary of the many
different kinds of
model based reasoning that you can
encounter in science
which just undermines the idea that
we're going to have once and for all
some
account of what science is like
now i'm sorry scientific models are like
now i you know i think that this kind of
move towards pluralism is something you
see
often in philosophy of science where you
know
someone notices that some something is
important to science
you start seeing people present accounts
that are supposed to describe how that
works
and then gradually we realize no there's
not one account that's going to work for
all of the cases under consideration
um and so uh i think that that's
um uh a wonderful starting point here
um to now discussing some of the the
specifics
of what professor magnani did yesterday
so um i uh
want to fully embrace this idea of
heterogeneity
but i i want to suggest that there's
perhaps a tension
between the
observation that there's no one model
that's going to provide a unified
sorry no one account it's going to
provide a unified treatment of all
scientific models
and um two of the key claims that i took
away
from professor magnani's talk so
um he made two very general claims
about models um one that they are not
fictions
now i'm interpreting this as a claim
that no models are fictions
um the second is that and this one the
the universal quantifier was very clear
in the talk
uh scientific models are never abstract
they are always concrete
um now this is one of the the two
questions i'll return to it at the end
um i'd really like to understand
more clearly what is at stake
in these claims in particular one aspect
of professor magnani's argument
yesterday
um which i thought i thought was very
nice uh was the observation
that terms like abstract object
and fiction fail to be load-bearing
um by which uh
i take it he means that um within
the scientific discourse the question of
whether or not
a particular model is abstract
or i mean the example that he gave us
within set theory
set is a load-bearing a term
but abstract object isn't so if you're
doing mathematics you aren't going
around trying to
determine whether various sets that you
might encounter
are abstract or not that doesn't enter
into your proofs it doesn't matter to
the sorts of things that you're
concerned with doing as a set theorist
whereas
being a set is the sort of thing that
matters
and so the idea here is that as i
understood it anyway
and please correct me if i have this
wrong is that
abstract object and fiction aren't
load-bearing within
model-based science no one is worried
when they present
a model whether or not it is a fiction
and for that reason um it seems that
uh fiction isn't isn't doing the right
kind of thing we shouldn't have an
account of scientific models according
to which they're fiction because
being fictions is not load-bearing
um but now i want to turn that on on its
head and ask
um if being an abstract isn't
load-bearing what is the alternative
like why is it that the alternative
is load-bearing why should we care about
them being concrete
or alternatively if being fiction is not
load-bearing
um what's at stake in saying that
they're
not fictions um okay so
we're gonna set that aside that's the
first question the second question
is one that uh um sort of builds on some
some other ideas that professor magnani
presented
which um i found
um very as i said at the beginning
inspiring so professor manyani presented
a picture
of uh scientific activity
as epistemic warfare
and the idea here is that science is a
struggle it's a struggle
for rational knowledge and it's one
where you need to draw on
as many weapons or tools or
um methods that uh
you can right you have to be
opportunistic you have to be ready to
um uh you know
do what it takes in order to uh come up
with
the knowledge that you need now from
this point of view
uh models are a tool they're a tool of
scientific creativity
he describes them as an epistemic weapon
which are intentionally built
and manipulated to the nociological
claims of increasing
scientific knowledge that's not yet
available
um now you know i think that this this
picture
of science as a a struggle is
um a very nice one
um you it it highlights something that
uh um the philosopher of science howard
stein also wrote about which is the
dialectic
character of science
um science isn't a static thing it's a
dynamic thing and it's a thing that
involves lots of back and forth um
where uh you know scientists
advance something they defend it perhaps
even beyond what they have
rational justification for and sometimes
that ends up
yielding new results that they wouldn't
have done otherwise in other cases it
forces retreats
where you give up things that you
thought you knew
um but it's it's a dynamic and changing
process that involves
um bringing lots of different
perspectives and and
methods to bear um
okay so let's let's accept
that picture of the scientific
enterprise
um i want to suggest that
there's a front here uh a front in the
you know the epistemic war
in which philosophy has a role to play
and i want to suggest that that role has
to do with
the analysis of
our methods and in particular an attempt
to understand
again using whatever methods we can we
can find
um whatever epidemic weapons we can
bring to bear
uh how and why the various
aspects of scientific activity that we
take to be successful
are successful now i want to suggest
that there are cases in which
um doing this you know reflecting on
how it is that our science is working
can lead to new scientific knowledge
through a kind of almost
self-consciously
philosophical analysis now in many cases
this
self-consciously philosophical analysis
isn't done by philosophers sometimes
it's done by mathematicians or by
scientists
um but it it does have a kind of
philosophical character
um insofar as it involves not just doing
science but asking questions about
science so i want to give an example
um that uh uh i hope
will clarify why i'm why i'm i'm
raising this suggestion so the example
is of uh um
the reinterpretation of ether theories
in the 19th century so
when uh james clerk maxwell first
presented um what we now think of as
maxwell's equations
his theory of the electromagnetic field
uh he included a discussion
of the
luminiferous ether through which
electromagnetic
waves were thought to propagate
now he actually gives
uh in his original paper and then
revises
over a series of subsequent papers
concrete specific i should be concrete
here not in a philosophically loaded
sense i should just say specific
specific mechanical models
of how the ether
worked right and you had this sort of
honeycomb pattern
of vortices and um
these would oscillate or you rotate in
different ways and
uh the other you know these little
circles will move around around the
vortices
and this is how electromagnetic waves
would propagate how they'd respond to
charges
and the idea was that you can give a
mechanical account of for instance
energy transfer in an electromagnetic
field and
the propagation of electric and magnetic
fields uh
due to charge and currents
now maxwell's accounts here
were in turned out to be inadequate in
various ways but there was a
major push within 19th century science
to identify
alternatives so other mechanical models
um that would reproduce
the same sorts of uh qualitative
features of the electromagnetic field
um throughout this tradition
there was a sincere belief that there
was an ether
that the ether had specific mechanical
properties
and that the goal of this modeling
activity was to
accurately represent the details
of these concrete physical systems
now towards the end of the 19th century
in fact the early
20th century um the mathematician and
physicist
andrey poincare responding to
a long history of
new ether models but also
[Music]
experimental evidence that didn't
support these specific ether models in
the way that some of their advocates
hoped
um he proposed a different way of
understanding
what maxwell's models were doing what he
suggested was that
maxwell shouldn't be interpreted as
giving
a mechanical explanation is the quote
maxwell does not give a mechanical
explanation of electricity and of
magnetism
he restricts himself to demonstrating
that that explanation is possible
and so what i i see fonquery doing here
is shifting from
thinking of ether models
as the sorts of things that are intended
to
accurately represent a concrete physical
system
to rather something that plays a
different role kind of how possibly role
right so you aren't trying to represent
a real physical system
you're trying to represent a fictional
physical system who cares if this is a
real system in fact the point isn't
to try to say anything about what the
actual ether is like if there even is an
ether
the point now is to establish certain
kinds of consistency relations
to show that energy and momentum are
related to electric and magnetic fields
in the right sorts of ways um to fit
together as a coherent physical system
irrespective of whether the ether itself
actually has any of the mechanical
properties
represented by these models this was
part of a general shift in the late 19th
century
i'm thinking of maxwell's theory as a
mechanical theory
of perturbations of the ether
to thinking of it as a system of
equations with certain phenomenological
properties
um and uh you know making certain kinds
of experimental predictions
and this was a stepping stone to special
relativity
because what einstein ultimately was
interested in is how can you
understand maxwell's equations in a way
that doesn't require the ether
now it seems to me as if poincare is
self-consciously philosophical analysis
of what role
models were playing in maxwell and you
know subsequent
work on maxwell's theory
allowed einstein so this is a stepping
stone in that it allowed einstein to
reconceive of the electromagnetic field
in a novel way
but part of that involved drawing a
distinction about the role
that models were playing where you went
from thinking of the model as
representing a real system to
a model as representing a fictional
system
now i i want to
to um suggest that there's something
important happening here where we aren't
thinking about
uh an account of models we aren't saying
all models are fictions
but rather what we're doing is we're
looking at a specific case
and we're saying uh that
within that context it's useful to be
able to draw a distinction
between different ways in which
uh a model might be doing its
representational work
and in this particular case i want to
suggest one of the ways is
as uh accurate representation something
like isomorphism to the world
and in the other case it's as a fiction
where the point is to establish that
certain sorts of relations are
consistent with one another
whether this actually has any special
any particular relationship to the
actual world or not
um i want to suggest that something
similar happens
when we talk about concrete or abstract
objects
um you might think
that uh the question are all models
abstract objects
um isn't a load-bearing term right this
was
suggested yesterday i'm totally
sympathetic to that
asset that level of abstraction i also
think though that there are really
useful distinctions that can be drawn in
particular cases
between models that are more concrete
and models that are more abstract
and that distinguishing between those is
itself
an example of an epistemic weapon that
we can use as part of our methodological
reflection
on the practice of science so i have
here examples of two ways of studying
fluid flows
one is set up wind tunnels
with concrete actually physical objects
that are shrunken down versions of the
sorts of objects whose
properties uh under fluid flow we're
interested in studying
right like a plane in a wind tunnel and
the alternative
of studying the same kind of problem by
trying to find solutions
for the navier-stokes equations and i
suggest that the latter
is far more abstract right i mean
drawing a distinction between
the experimental you know physical model
approach and the
uh the abstract mathematical approach
seems to me to
to be a key methodological insight here
um and one that you you um i think
lose if you uh try to to say that all
models are
concrete not abstract in you know every
relevant sense
um okay and so this leads to my two
questions that i want to
to lead off with here and the first is
as i said before um if we're to think of
abstract object in fiction as not
load-bearing terms and i wonder
what we gain by denying that
models are abstract and fictions
why does saying that models are concrete
barrel load if denying that models are
concrete does not bear a load
um that's the first question in the
second one is i wonder and this is
really just an invitation to say more
whether you see any positive epistemic
roles
for some of the doctrines that you
argued against in your talk such as
fictionalism and so um do you think that
there are contexts
where emphasizing the analogies between
at least some models and fictions can
turn out to be fruitful
and you know similarly what about
distinguishing
between more or less abstract models as
a way perhaps of understanding
what the different epistemic benefits of
these different kinds of modeling
practices might be
okay and that's the uh the end of the
slides that i prepared
great um uh thanks jim so um
lorenzo did you want to tackle uh that
sort of two questions
i think he's muted still um yeah i'm
asking him
sorry so thank you for you are very
rich and stimulating
comment to my presentation and also
about
other things other things so to answer
your question i have to start
from the first part of your comment
to explain that that
the the birth of the interest
about model is related
to the fact that during during the last
century the epistemological
interest in science but
also the self-image
of scientists about science was
mainly devoted to
its structure its static
structure so when
mo when the interest about models
arises this
interest is ambiguous
at the beginnings because on one part
it is related to see models
in a static way so you have a theory you
said the interest was in theories
you have a theory you have a textbook
and there are models
that are part of this theory on the
other side
the interesting models is related
to the fact that the post-positivist
philosophy of science that is proper
kuna lakatos feraben emphasizes
the dynamic of scientific knowledge
and so you people discovered that
models are an important part
of the process of scientific discovery
indeed yesterday i said i
think that the most important
aspect of models in science
is related to scientific discovery
so
you you you uh uh proposed
so this is a kind of of a historical
explanation
of the new in
interest in models that we faced in the
last
part of the last century so you
also say that
you agree i think that you agree with me
that models are extremely
heterogeneous so we cannot have a
unified
model of of them
but you also say that
the idea of epistemic warf
warfare can
make room also to
a new role of epistemology and
i think that we can show
some aspects of this new role for
instance to indicate
you said they may thought that we have
to use
but for instance also some basic aspect
yesterday
i said discoverability is a problem
for instance in a recent paper
paper in the british journal of the
philosophy of science
there is a research in which the the
authors
are examining how different degrees of
connectedness of scientists
impact their efficiency
in knowledge acquisition and
the results they they found
find suggest that whether
and to what extent the degree of
connectedness
of a scientific community impacts
its efficiency in a highly
context-dependent matter
since different conditions
deem different results so this is an
interesting result result because we can
see in this case that that
connectedness is strongly related to the
context
so me too i think
that the contest the context in which
scientific research is occurring
is important for instance i think
also taking advantage of my studies
about
abduction that what i call eco
maximization maximization of
eco-cognitive openness
is extremely important things in science
in scientific discovery so you cannot
ever what i call locked
strategies so and in this sense
for instance when you see some
areas of science in which there is an
excess of
patenting and so on so knowledge is no
more emotional
so this is exactly the contrary of the
portality of modern science but
so i i totally agree agree with you when
you uh pointed
out out the this problem of uh
making epistemology in a new perspective
in a new perspective
as a as a as a part of epistemic warfare
so yeah this is a an idea that i totally
totally agree now there is the the pro
the problem that the that is related
also to your
explicit question that i said
and fiction abstractness
concreteness and so on so i
said models
are never abstract because they are
always concrete so you say also concrete
is not a load-bearing predicate
okay the problem is that
in my case i am adopting an
epistemological perspective that
is strongly related to
cognitive science so when i see
a concrete object i see a concrete
object
object not in a philosophical sense but
adopting a kind of a scientific
view it is a result of science that
if you have a mental image
this is a concrete physical and
biological event
when you write a some
proof in a sheet of paper this is a
concrete
object so i prefer
to adopt this idea
of concrete objects
because they are in tune with
the recent result of cognitive science
for instance about distributed cognition
extended mind embodied mind
so the results that
emphasize the interplay
between internal representation
and external representation but
as i said i also said that
um lorenzo i just had a quick question
um i was just wondering
you know where does sort of surrender
pity fit in
in this sort of serendipitous
discoveries right so
where does that fit in into this rubric
when we're talking about
sort of you know extended mind and okay
okay so it do do you remember when
i presented that example taken
from a a ethnographic research
of nerve session and chandrasekhar so
you see
in that case two concrete models
and in vitro models and a computational
model
of the same situation that
thanks to the fact that you manipulate
the model
and you internalize the model the
intertwine between
internal and external uh relationships
is the producer of something new
so in in this case but to to come back
to to james
observations of course we can still
use up the adjective
abstract because of course there are
differences
it i said yesterday they are absolutely
in a pequenia piquinia
sense because they are always concrete
objects from a cognitive
science point of view if you adopt
a naturalistic perspective about these
things
in which you you you for instance you
said what
are what are scientific models this is
not an interesting
question because it is old-fashioned it
is a pre-kantians
as i as i said yesterday so this is
my my answer that i
think that avoid
some parts of the old lexicon
about scientific discovery is
more in tune with
the possibility of managing
and a novel epistemological view of
science
so the if you use
the term fiction fiction is intended
not as a falsity is intended
as a character of a romance
like anaharian i do not think
that it is good that it that
is productive to use that term
but of course you can also use it in
some
historical analysis but
i would prefer to avoid
to transform the epistemology of model
based reasoning
in a kind of let me say
empty dialectics
between journal papers
in which there is a john that says
in my opinion fiction is abc
then
[Music]
mario arrives and say no i think that
there is also the situation e and then
there is
elizabeth that says okay but in this
case
because in this case
i think that that we are trapped
in a kind of
scholastic not in the sense of medieval
scholastic
not in the sense of the philosophy
philosophy of neuroscholastic but the
industry
something pedantic and something
as for instance daniel
dennett says in a bit
aggressive way i have to say
to produce a philosophical
proliferation of papers
he says characterized by
abiding insignificance
so it is terrible so but i would prefer
to avoid
to see the destiny of epistemology as a
kind of struggle
of micro niches micro academic
niches and i think that
fiction is itself is also acceptable
but fictionalism opened
the the door of this kind of making
epistemology philosophy
that i have to be sincere i do not like
so much
so i think that i was able to answer
almost everything because
consider also that the concept of
fiction
for instance there is this observation
this is my last uh
counter observation of an author called
levy that correctly say
that the concept of fiction derives from
walton view of
[Music]
make-believe the idea of make-believe
but he says in walton view
fiction are intended
as
[Music]
as a
a set of authors
produced in order to get
no sorry make believe that these
fiction are intended something
like uh some
some promoters of ruleba
your rule-based practices
but levy sales in reality
fiction in literature
are relatively strongly related to the
authors
and their intentions treating
interpretation
as a near thousand of the practices
we employ in everyday communication
that is with natural language
that is the the literary language
of romances of course is related to
everyday language
so this is not the case of the epistemic
warfare
so fiction also from this perspective
is not particularly adequate because
it is related to the everyday
communication
and the intention of the author when
invents
a fiction is to
to promote any imagination
in the audience they are directed by the
authors
okay so these are my observations about
your uh your you are noticed that
i appreciate the loss i think that
okay okay of course you said
earth are fiction fruitful why not
you can use frictions but when you
when you make an example like yours
about
maxwell uh poincare
and einstein but not in the case of a
kind of
struggles between an academic
micro niche microage
so uh i i just want to sort of draw out
a few things
so first um it it seems to me as if
uh the um
there's sort of a few different levels
going on here one is
um that so for instance when you say
that that
models are are never abstract um
in part what you're doing is
highlighting a background commitment
to physicalism and a
kind of uh cognitive science
attitude towards how to think about
scientific practice
um and so you know in some sense tell me
if this is wrong it sounds like you're
you're denying the existence of abstract
objects in the sort of
broadly platonic sense altogether um
which is fine right i mean so
that's just how you know mathematical
objects are also things that that are
are realized as particular
configurations of neurons and
you know are shared in complex ways um
and uh that's compatible with
nonetheless
pointing to examples of um
uh actual scientific practice and saying
well
this kind of modeling does seem to be
using a different
kind of structure than this other kind
of modeling you know drawing
distinctions
in that context makes sense i mean it
i i take it does that
i mean you we can still say that numbers
are different from chairs
even though it's not the case that
numbers are not
themselves um uh the sorts of things
that are
are uh uh uh you know exist
independently of
yeah abstract in this this particular
sentence you're rejecting does that
sound
right okay but i i agree with you
so yeah the problem is that also in
mathematics
uh always you have to deal with
something written
with something written so there is this
interplay between
written things and the internalization
so the same happens also in religion in
some sense
because because the the the secular
texts
are written so they
have to be something not
only spiritual you know and
if you approach scientific
discovery in this case mathematical
discovery
of course you can use the
the adjective abstract it is
good but you
also have to check what
happens for instance in proofs
in written proofs and not only from the
propositional
and symbolic points of view but also
from the point of view of their iconic
shapes
because when i i i i was able to talk
with some mathematicians
and they said when we are dealing with a
proof
we also check we also see the shape
of the proof that is something visual
something iconic
that of course it is
an externality concrete okay
concrete that affords
something new in the mind because you
re-represent
what you have manipulated outside
to reach new affordances
so this is also this also happens in the
case
of mathematics i showed the example of
vlobachevsky
because the bachelski was still using
geometrical diagrams like in the
elementary
mathematics the euclidean mathematics in
that case the diagram was
completely important but also in modern
mathematical
mathematics that doesn't use diagrams
there is the problem of proofs also in
logic
and in this case okay you have abstract
object
objects but
you have to see also the way in which
they are really existent in concrete
objects by the way a last
observation leibniz used
the expression fiction okay
fiction uh in french because like
it's invented together with newton the
infinitesimal calculus
the the differential the the
the x but he may immediately discovered
that the dates
doesn't exist is very is wonderful for
making a calculation
but you you cannot find that in the in
the set
of the real numbers the infinitesimal
and he called fiction bien from day
that is something that doesn't exist
but that is able to in this case
i you can use this is a smart use
on the part of leibniz and you know
that in the 60s of the last century
abraham robinson built
the non-standard analysis in which there
are infinitesimal and infinite
numbers and so
the infinitesimal is no more a fiction
in non-standard analysis
analysis so this is a case in which the
the the you the leibnizian use
of the word fiction was clear
and the bien from the fiction performed
and also
also libel its observation was given
from there
so yeah um that is a useful
clarification
that i i didn't know that the fiction
originated from
sort of leibniz but that explains why
you cannot
use it to mean either falsity or
imaginary right that you cannot okay
okay okay consider that
live list of course use the fiction
fictions or fiction the word fiction
also derives from latin
okay but the men meet the main meaning
of the finger in latin
stranger exactly like in italian
the main meaning the first meaning and
also i i make a researcher on on this
aspect
and also in 16
no in 15th century english
in in england
the first beanie was to shape
to form to build
it is only a secondary meaning
the one that is related to romans
two characters in a play and so on
so there is also this ambiguity it is
ambiguity
in the case of
live blitz fiction was used in an
epistemological
good sense as a falsity as
something that doesn't have a reference
so it it was not use
equating it to
a character literary character and
the usual career
yes okay thank you at this point jim if
you
um if you had any for follow-up
questions uh please go ahead otherwise
we can also open up i think we have the
chat
open i don't see any questions yet
but um meanwhile feel free to follow up
jim with um um
yes yeah i mean so
i i'm curious um
so
there's something when we talk about
mathematical objects
um you know and this is going a little
bit a little bit
uh a field of the
the um you know the the
specific issues addressing the talk and
sort of highlighting some of these
you know responding to some of these
sort of background uh
ideas that we've just been discussing um
there's a a sense in which
the you know many different con concrete
in in your sense right of you know sort
of specific mental
uh you know realizations you know in
brain states right
of of uh mathematical things
um uh share something with one another
right and as a mathematician you would
think of this as you know they're being
different
concrete representations of what
mathematicians would call an abstract
thing right so in the context of group
theory for instance you would have many
different representations of the
abstract group
um abstract here being used in a
mathematical sense not in a
metaphysical sense um but i wonder
though if that
how to understand that same kind of
relationship
um you know so for instance your
concrete representation of
set and my concrete representation of
set
uh presumably share some properties
um they don't necess they don't seem to
need to share their physical properties
i presume that
our brains are distinct number one but
also number two that that you know
the concept would be realized quite
quite differently physically
in you know
different people and yet nonetheless
there's something that they share
and you know that idea that something
that they share
is often what people have in mind when
they talk about what the abstract object
is now i think that you can talk about
that in a fairly
non-metaphysically loaded way
but um i'm curious how you think about
it
okay so i i think that if you are a
mathematician
you can write something and you can
show this object only because you
wrote something so you can communicate
because it is more difficult
to communicate something that is not
externalized
and you can see what another
mathematician
wrote and you can see similarities for
instance
and you can arrive together to
share what i called in the presentation
yesterday
a manifest model so
something that it is shared and then
at and that can be the base
the basis of further ideas
but something similar happens also in
the case
of natural language because
only with the speech it is impossible
to build a shared language
you you also need a kind of written
language then can be also a tool for
communication
so this is a way the
externalization is also
a way a method for the collective
enterprise in science in the case of
natural language
is of course building
the written natural language is a way of
communicating in general way among the
new human beings
and also you find that you find
the possibility of scaffolding your
thoughts
with written natural language because
only speech the speech of the primitives
is not sufficient you know they are
so you do you do not have a syntactic
language
like uh sapience appears as
in the case of mathematics you can see
something similar
in the case it is necessary
to share a research
and to build some results that are
collectives if you are a genius and you
are alone you can write
and continue the interplay with your
externalization
in a blackboard in a sheet of paper
using using a computer and so on
so so you see it sounds like you don't
think then so if you know if i have
let's let's talk about a specific model
one that you mentioned yesterday the
latka volterra model okay these are just
some
couple differential equations describing
predator prey relations
um i go and i do my analysis of them i
come up with some solutions and i
you know consider how populations of
predators and prey interact
you go and do the same um it sounds like
there's not a sense on your view in
which
i you and i have both analyzed the same
model
because i've got my internal
representation and i've written things
down and i've made you know particular
marks on my page and all of that or the
those are the concrete things that that
you want to say are the model um you've
done yours as well
you've come up with different concrete
internal representations and concrete
external ones
um but it seems to me as if there's
there really ought to be some strong
sense in which
uh we've studied the same thing
um and i'm i'm i'm trying to understand
it seems to me like maybe you're
sort of even more strongly committed to
the non-existence of abstract objects
than uh uh than i would want to be
because i want to
maintain that there's some sense at
least in which even if i don't believe
in say platonic forms nonetheless
there's something that we have both done
we have both analyzed the same model
okay so in the case of the logical
volterra equations the problem is that
it was not necessarily a kind of process
of of collective
discovery they were so able to build
immediately those equations
that they were the fortunate model
immediately so there was not this
problem but
imagine for instance the case of
the discovery of non-euclidean
geometries that i know
there were there was 2 000
years of speculations
and drawings about
the fifth postulate of the parallel
lines
so for lobacek bernard
riemann gauss and
others there were already available
a lot of externalized objects
and they finally found
the final manifest model that
suddenly became the discovery of
non-euclidean geometries
and it was in the case of the the
depiction of the
postulate was not dissimilar uh
from the uh depiction of the parallel
postulates
made for instance by sarcaria the
gerometers that
were stopped they were not able to see
something new
okay and in this case
you can you finally arrive
to a discovery that you can share
thanks to the fact that you worked
with analogical with
no excuse me not analogical with similar
drawings similar images externalized
of course because i told you in this
case it is
it is a fortunate case between
mathematics because
uh until the the
19th century the mathematicians still
use the
euclidean diagrams
so very strong externalized
objects also euler and
other mathematicians do you agree with
this idea
well i i see um uh
i see that there was a long process of
um
uh of discovery here
2 000 years yes right and that it was a
collective activity
um what i'm i'm uh
not sure of is whether i would agree
that um so it seems to me as a perfectly
reasonable way of characterizing
uh this situation was that uh you had a
group of people who were trying to
uh determine whether or not uh
um two things one uh
euclid's other axioms implied using
particular pretty well defined logical
operations
uh implied the fifth postulate
um and you know the other side of that
whether or not this particular
intended model and now in the
mathematical sense of model
of euclid's axioms
was the unique model of euclid's axioms
without the fifth postulate
which of course from the 19th century
logical point of view we now understand
to be the same question
right if it the the other other
axioms do imply the fifth postulate the
parallel postulate
then it would turn out that every model
in the mathematical sense would have to
realize that um if not then there would
be
you know what we now know our
non-euclidean geometry is um
i it seems to me as if i i'm more
inclined to think that they're they're
uh
you know the um parallel postulate never
followed from the other axioms
that this was something that was true in
euclid's day we didn't know it euclid
didn't know it
um it wasn't something that was um
only became true through some process of
sharing diagrams and collective activity
that was the process by which we worked
out this consequence
but i just this is you know
um i'm not sure to what extent is just a
matter of speaking
that i want to say you know there's this
thing
the euclidean plane um where the
parallel postulate is true
uh but where there are also these other
things like the
you know um uh you know hyperbolic
plane where the parallel postulate is
false uh but where all the other
axioms of euclid's geometry are true
um and that was as much the case when
euclid was working as it was
when people finally you know when
lubashevsky finally did his work
um
yes i i i agree consider that
for for two thousand years they thought
that
the fifth postulate was a problem an
anomaly
you know but the discovery of the
nuclear geometries
the uh concluded that the fifth posteris
is okay he's a good postulate
the problem is that there are also other
possibilities
but for instance also a researcher
exactly of my university discovered a
lot of theorems of non-euclidean
geometry
the name is the sakeri jerome zakiri
but he absolutely was not aware of this
fact
and they eliminated these uh
these theorems because he considered
them
contradictory you know and he said okay
so we have to save the fifth
postulate but he was not able to
discover the new geometry
so this is an example of
externalized proofs
observation also philosophical
considerations of various kind
that constituted the eco-cognitive
setting
setting in which lobacek
riemann and the others discovered
new ideas and this is of the field of
mathematics
in which there is not the problem of
empirical confirmation
because it is a a priori science
there is not the problem of
experimentation
but there is still the problem
of what lachatus imre architectures
called
demonstrations and computations so
this dynamic interplay of
certified discovery in mathematics too
good this was a very interesting
discussion
i know with james and
priya and also
yesterday yeah when
when you when you said that problem
of the conditions of possibility
of creating and making
good models and this is terrible you
know because it is like
to find the condition of possibilities
of winning a chess game
okay but you are right and
james 2 is right because it is in my
opinion the same problem
we have to take care of
the eco-cognitive settings
in which our contemporary science
is located because with the
bad echo cognitive said settings
we jeopardize discoverability
even if you are in presence of a genius
because the genius cannot exercise
his powers without a good
uh epistemic niche you can you can also
call
it an epistemic niche taking advantage
of the
evolutionary new theory of the cognitive
niches
this is a kind of epistemic niche in
which
as i told you as i told you
openness is important i i prefer the
book
that i a small book that with the title
the title is discoverability
about uh and the subtitle is also
the is also a bit provocative the
ecological the urgent
ecological need
of protecting human creativity
right okay that is about
me about this problem yeah uh so great
um i don't see any questions in the chat
so we should
go ahead i'm sorry yeah no right
i mean no no i think we're listening and
um
also it's getting late for you so this
was absolutely wonderful
thank you both thank you lorenzo thank
you so much jim
for thank you james to you and
take care and have a lovely weekend and
um
and see you soon bye
[Music]
and thanks everyone for attending